hey guys look I don't really have a pic
I have more of a find we're now here
inside the observatory and we're joined
by a special guest one was strong New
York City ties no way introduce yourself
my name ladies gentleman is Jeff
Goldblum and I do have some ties to New
York City
I love New York City yeah I'm gonna get
people a big rundown of your resume and
then we're asking some more questions
but your life yeah here we go you ready
for this
see if you remember all these okay he
has starred ladies and gentlemen in
popular Hollywood movies like Jurassic
Park you might remember him shirtless
the fly you might remember him as
shirtless okay independence day probably
shirtless know you were scientists and
that one may be briefly for a little
while but it's right here in the Big
Apple where he got his start at 17 years
old
Goldblum left his native Pittsburgh to
study acting at New York's famed
Neighborhood Playhouse famed before you
got there a famed after oh no no no very
famous before because of Sanford Meisner
Prince of blue did you ever hear of him
he's a great acting teacher and he was
teaching he had taught there before made
it famous and I think and then he was
teaching when I was making more famous
because soon after you had a Broadway
debut in the Tony Tony award-winning
musical to Gentlemen of Verona
yes no I'm not always him sure if I was
in the state right it's a Shakespearean
play it's Shakespeare
but we made a musical out of it they
made a musical out of it was a big big
hit that was my first job first job yeah
how does acting compare how does acting
in a Broadway play compared to say what
you're doing now with the world
according to Jeff Goldblum new show
where you're kind of doing what we're
doing where you like you walk around you
look at stuff you report on things a
little bit you do it so well
no I sit at your feet you're very
masterful I'm doing this show I like
this show and how is it good question
how does it compare well I don't know
playing yourself in this basically yes I
am yeah just like you now but yeah it's
it's fun it's on Disney Plus yeah we did
12 of them already three have been
stream did you see any of them there was
one on sneakers denim ice cream was
coming out this Friday you
did you know that it's progressionist
fantastic ice cream you growing up there
well Isley's yes we we reference it in
the show have you ever been been to
Pittsburgh Pittsburgh there was a place
called eyes Lisa what do ice cream
you're talking about
there was a top-10 place like 15 years
ago and I made a special trip there it
was terrific you did yeah where did you
what flavors you get chocolate chip
cookie dough are these my favorite
what's the most interesting thing you've
learned on your wanderings for this show
the world accordingly so many
interesting things I'll tell you we did
a pools episode you were telling me that
you also were going to set sensory
deprivation tank I also did for that
episode we went to raging waters I'd
never been to a waterpark before but we
went to NASA the NASA neutral buoyancy
lab in Houston Texas where they have the
biggest pool anywhere at the bottom as a
replica of the International Space
Station I talked to a couple of
astronaut trainees women spectacular
women who were at the end of their
two-year program went for six hours in
their spacesuits in order to simulate
weightlessness in order to wart dude
their work I put on fins and snorkel and
went in with them and died today but I
talked to astronauts who had been up
there one of them told me a very
interesting thing listen to this but
everybody who's been up there for like
four or five months only men not the
women who have been up there but the men
come back with something wrong with
their right eye not their left eye but
always their right eye that it does
something like that and it's waving we
have no idea what's going on with it but
anyway we learned a lot of interesting
stuff NatGeo is the producer they're
very smart the world is full of
mysteries we've not plumbed the depths
of this planet we have much to do you
said a mouthful I did yeah we should do
a show together on mysteries but
actually first I want to ask you
something here's a mystery for you this
is a big mystery we did a poll you know
we walk around we asked a bunch of
Americans something we say what's your
favorite kind of music only 7% of
Americans surveyed by CBS News seven
percent said jazz news you can't argue
with CBS news what the people are saying
the people are saying I have my ear to
what the people are saying I like that
jazz music you know I like it and people
who come to our shows seem to like it
and we put yeah you do that is that is
me
yeah we play a kind of music that is
kind of 50s 60s blue note for these two
albums that we've now put out on deck of
the last one came out it's called I
shouldn't be telling you this and it's
fun it's like what jazz was originally
in some quarters fun and romantic and
social music and dance music but we have
singers on this album like Fiona Apple
and Miley Cyrus I'm Gregory Porter and
Sharon Van Etten and it's really fun you
know I don't know if you were watching
earlier but we teased a little bit of a
quiz we're gonna do here so you know the
world and the world according to you all
right here's the quiz question number
one are you ready yeah I know I'm not
really ready because I don't have it on
me get it for memory though okay how
long does it take to wash all 6,000
windows here on the Empire State
Building is it for days for weeks or
four months or four years I would say
all 6,000 win the thousand when they're
asked is how many people on the team on
the window Washington know I had the
very same question and I didn't get an
answer but I'm presuming about to to
thinking to two guys to do 6,000 windows
I'd say not four days what was the
second one four four weeks four minds or
you say four weeks let's say I'm in fact
you are incorrect sir yes four months or
hey well they get to the end they just
go right back to the beginning okay
that's shake it off shake it off
question two questions - is everyone
ready okay so this building here where
we are is about 1,400 feet tall how much
does it weigh come on you're asking the
wrong guy but let me guess I'm multiple
choice on this one - or no no okay shy
at it all right okay how much is this
building way yes how much is away idea
but I would say let's say 30 tons of no
idea 30 time though it'll take two tons
365,000 tons tons watch hey blows my
mind - it boggles the mind it really
does Holly but all right well while our
minds boggle here let's toss it back to
- Anthony and Gail in the studio
why don't you get the toggle you can
toss back now take Manhattan the Bronx
and Staten Island what's your favorite
New York song I was thinking about a
bunch of them this morning though there
was a one from a Jerry Lewis and Dean
Martin movie called if it goes like this
every street we like you you'll you'll
get a kick out of this last week when we
were planning this show Tony to copal
said god I'm so bummed that I'm gonna
miss Jeff Goldblum in the studio I've
always wanted to talk to you isn't
exactly that's exactly what he said then
it turns out he gets you all to himself
I know I miss you and I miss you Anthony
but I'm glad I talked to you it's a
great pleasure well thank you very much